if you are prone to anxiety and
something I said on the internet gives
you lifelong anxiety it's not me that's
the problem it's you and you need to get
therapy for your anxiety until you're
better I can imagine situations in which
I would say like I wish I could say
something hateful towards a group of
people or towards a particular person
that's that's going to sort of
affect them it's going to it's going to
harm them and it's going to harm them in
a way that's not threatening their life
it's not going to destroy their
reputation but it but it causes them a
form of harm but this kind of
justification for uh for hate speech
laws is not only rejected but often
laughed out of the room by Free Speech
Advocates it's it's it's parodied it's
it's seen as infantile the idea that you
should be protected from words they're
just words you need to learn how to
toughen up a little bit I don't care if
you're going to be a bit upset I don't
care if you're going to feel anxious you
know people develop
lifelong anxiety problems based on hate
speech and sure that might be I'm almost
certain that they do and it it might be
like irrational it might be a sort of an
overreaction let's say but it's not like
they chose to be of such a as you would
see a probably weak psychological
Constitution it's not their fault but
they're the kindness I don't think
that's what happens I think what you're
talking about is people being bullied as
children and called names and mocked for
their appearance or for their skin color
or whatever right but I know I'm not
saying that children in the playground
should be able to be racist to each
other and that's the point of free
speech right because when you're talking
about children there's also an element
of it's it's an educational environment
right and these things but my point is
these things are best regulated by the
school the parents right whatever right
but what would I have to say to you to
give your lifelong anxiety well it takes
a lot to make me cry but there are there
are lots of people
um who
I mean I mean we see it because we see
stories that people that people take the
piss out of because they'll see a story
that someone said something that's you
know made people feel anxious or that's
given someone a panic attack or
something like that and people often
make fun of this because they think it
it shows how sort of you know weak and
snow flaky the lips are right but the
fact that we're able to sort of make a
joke like that demonstrates that they do
exist such people no it doesn't
necessarily demonstrate that at all what
it demonstrates is that there are some
people who have worked out they're
complaining about the speech of others
is a very good way to get attention so
let's say that for your course let's say
them for example that I sort of wrote
the blog that used your usual words and
I monetized it and I made sort of like
20 pounds off it didn't actually do that
well because most people were like well
this is someone else's book I'm just
going to go and buy the book it's not
necessarily about how much money you
made it's about how much money I lost
but carry on so 20 pounds let's say I
lost 20 pounds or maybe you lost 10
pounds because one of the people
wouldn't otherwise have bought the book
something like this right so it's sort
of a sort of a negligible amount of
money yeah and then you you try to
assuming you say you can't do this and I
say something like oh look man it says
it's 10 pounds yeah you know like but
that's why I would never see you in that
situation but but you'd have the right
to and I think you'd probably want to
defend the right of an author to do such
a thing yes but couldn't I say something
similar which is that like
yeah sure these words that you're
writing are kind of harmful but they're
so minimal especially if there's no way
for me to avoid the harm
and I don't think there's a way for
somebody who's of course prone to
anxiety also if you are prone to anxiety
and something I said on the internet
gives you lifelong anxiety it's not me
that's the problem it's you and you need
to get therapy for your anxiety until
you're better
perhaps but it's not like somebody
chooses to be in that situation to start
with right I I'm not suggesting they do
what I'm saying is they're choosing not
to change the situation that they're in
by see by not seeking the support they
need to deal with what is an underlying
mental health problem it's possible they
don't realize that it's lurking there
until it's in that case I'm doing them a
great service by pointing it out and I
yeah well perhaps that's interesting um
I this is my attitude to all of this
stuff because
um I am someone who's as I say uh I'm a
very different person to the person I
was 20 years ago and one of the reasons
is I've purposefully sought out uh ways
of thinking and ways of rewiring my
brain uh to be
more resilient to be able to deal with
difficult things to deal with anxieties
I felt about all sorts of things and and
that's why I'm not I'm not someone who
is careless I'm not saying what I'm
saying as a as a trying to own anyone
I'm saying what I'm saying from a point
of view which is I know that everyone
experiences anxiety over something and
the fact that you experience anxieties
number one not to be unexpected you're a
human being anxiety is part of life
number two if you don't like
experiencing anxiety when other people
say things you don't like you are the
person responsible for dealing with that
and that is the best way for you to live
your life that's the best way for me to
live my life that's why when
like when I turned down that contract
and a comedian uh well comedian uh Kate
smithway uh said insinuated that I was
alright and a naughty I make jokes about
it instead of suing her which I'm sure I
could right because while I do think
it's important for me to be able to and
go and defend myself in court against
deeply damaging allegations I don't
think the fact that Kate smithweight
called me something is necessarily
detrimental to my reputation or to my
character uh what would be detrimental
to my character is if every time
somebody said something nasty about me
on the internet I decided to internalize
that and go oh someone called me ugly
someone called me fat someone called me
skinny someone called me this therefore
I'm now anxious that would be the worst
possible thing for me to do so I'm not
saying what I'm saying out of a lack of
compassion I just don't think it's
healthy to take the words that other
people say and internalize them as
something that means you now have to
experience emotions about you see what I
mean and I am someone who as we talked
about has a you know with Francis we
have a large YouTube channel you can
imagine that not all the comments we
always get are necessarily positive and
helpful and supportive oh yeah right now
I'm not
going out there and going you know
hurtful comments on my YouTube channel
should be controlled or measured or they
cause me anxiety because if I find that
they cause me anxiety it's up to me to
deal with it in the ways that I've
described or it's up to me not to read
them right I can't not not experience
pain if you punch me in the face I can
not read comments that I don't want to
read on it
foreign